fame yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
pete davidson is dropping everything for
his leading lady
on season two of the kardashians pete's
running to have a steamy shower with
girlfriend kim kardashian life is good i
have a new boyfriend i'm just having a
really good time babe yeah do you want
to shower with me really quick
yeah that's a glimpse of the season 2
teaser for the family's hulu reality
series without missing a beat pete
agrees to hop in the shower and we're
just as shocked as kim's sister chloe
genuinely i cannot believe it things
have been heating up between kim and
pete since they went public with their
romance back in october 2021 it's always
so much fun well we have a feeling we'll
see more pda from keith this season
along with the behind the scenes look at
the whole family at least that's what
they teased to e.t before season one i
think for every sister we have different
boundary levels and we all try to
respect that and probably moving forward
we might all have and like your
boundaries are allowed to change and
mine will probably change later i wanted
to believe that tristan could change i
wanted to trust him and it seems chloe
isn't letting last season's drama with
her ex tristan thompson and his
paternity scandal ruin her shot at
finding the one
i do believe in love when you love you
know you're alive you have these
feelings of course the drama continues
in other areas looks like we'll get to
see how the blac chyna legal battle all
went down
she's suing us for over 100 million
dollars and we're leaving our fate in
the hands of 12 random people what if
they hate us and get ready for some
heart dropping moments too when family
matriarch kris jenner lands in the
hospital
i don't know what's happening with you i
can't tell my kids i'm scared they have
enough problems they don't need to worry
about mom the episodes are more a little
bit documentary style and i think that
you have a real insight into what the
girls are doing not only you know what
you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes some
moments we can't wait to see kylie
jenner welcoming her second child who
was named wolf and maybe in season two
we'll finally find out his official name
i made a baby this is my 11th grandchild
this is definitely a massive birth
control moment for me it's a lot
looks like kendall continues to avoid
any baby talk but she's thriving in her
career as a runway model
and more kravis is on the way their
standard pda is there plus we'll see
them planning for their wedding
courtney's saying yes to the dolce and
gabbana dress ahead of her and travis's
italian nuptials we are starting to talk
wedding dresses
what is in the media is sort of things
that we feel we need to film because
it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long the countdown is on season two of
the kardashian drops on september 22nd
no matter how crazy things are
we're always going to be family
[Music]